a couple of things prompted me to leave
England I had a health scare
there was a doctor found a lump in my
breast and and I had to wait a week to
find out if it was canceled or not and
in that week I made a list of all the
things that I would do if it wasn't
cancer and the number one thing was
moved to California because I'd always
wanted to just try it and so I booked a
one-way ticket as soon as I got the
all-clear and never looked back
thank God I did everyone told me not to
everyone said I was too old I was 28
everyone said I was too fat I was a size
six okay and everyone said I was too
ethnic and they can go i'm community mel
and today i'm unfiltered if I could
describe myself in a few words I'd say
brave ridiculous and authentic the first
time I recognized Beauty was probably
watching a Disney Princess and thinking
that beauty was long blonde hair and
white skin and a waist that was that big
and I think that probably haunted me up
until now I think my first memory of
makeup was in my 20s that's when I
really started to use it on myself and I
was very bad at it and I used to wear it
so thick like war paint
almost as though that was my armor going
out into the world and so you could
never really see my skin and it couldn't
breathe and it wasn't really until I
started dating the man I'm currently
with that I stopped wearing makeup
outside and started to just generally
wear less because he preferred my face
first thing in the morning and made me
feel comfortable my skin
[Music]
I have no sense of how you're supposed
to do this carefully I just scrub it off
with a mic I can't be bothered with all
the stuff that you're supposed to do
it's fine I think it's all a scam
growing up in London was interesting it
was a racist time in London so it was
hard to make friends when I was younger
I was also deaf until I was 12 so that
was its own kind of alienating
experience it was great in a way cuz it
made me a quiet person even though I
don't seem that way on my Twitter but it
also made me a very observant person
which I think has kept me very safe in
this industry I didn't ever have a sense
of belonging until I was in my 20s I was
just I was felt different I was always
treated badly for being different and I
was very academic and I didn't drink I
didn't smoke I didn't do drugs I wasn't
cool I think the greatest thing was
growing up and learning but your school
is just four walls and there's a whole
world out there beyond your school so if
you are someone who doesn't currently
fit in please remember if you just hang
on you'll be able to find your tribe on
the outside so to sum up my career very
quickly I wanted to be a doctor because
I am South Asian as pork and then I was
hit by a car into another car broke my
back was in bed for about a year and a
half decided not to go back to school so
therefore couldn't be a doctor became an
English teacher instead and then got
scouted by a TV producer who asked me to
go to the biggest audition in the
country for a TV hosting job on channel
4 in England somehow I got that job with
no previous experience and a week later
I was live on national television and a
year after that I got my own show of a
year after that I started my own
magazine column a year after that I
started on BBC Radio I'm here to deliver
unto you all of the latest chart news
and gossip in less time than it takes to
make a cup of tea and then at about 28 I
became bored I became tired I felt like
they weren't enough opportunities for
women especially at women of colour so I
came to America with a one-way ticket
and I never left it's been five years my
first audition here was the good place I
had never acted before but for some
reason mic sure
no sense and is a lunatic and gave me
the job and now I'm here hello can I
just say I love your house it's just so
tiny and cute it's like a little child's
plaything like for a family of mice I
really like doing things that I I'm
afraid of and that I you know I think
there's tremendous nobility and trying
something that there isn't guaranteed
success in I think we live in a
generation that only values success and
winning and perfection and I'm not
interested in that I never have been you
know as women were always told what
we're capable of which is not much and
that's why we're told that we have to be
so beautiful because we have no other
value and so I really like pushing
against that and seeing what I can do
what I'm capable of outside of a man's
dictation of my value
I love these wipes so I love a wipe and
makeup artists are always horrified by
me I think they're so pretentious it's
fine I've been using wipes for 11 years
my skin's fine like it's it's a scam I
don't really watch myself on camera
because I have body dysmorphia so I find
it a real struggle so I have to kind of
peek through my fingers almost the good
place when I'm watching it but generally
it's just exciting when I do see myself
to see the people that I'm around mostly
I think those are the ones I focus on
where it's like oh my god I'm on screen
with Ted Danson or with Maya Rudolph or
with Jim Carrey I think those are the
things that are magical about being on
TV here generally just to be in this
industry such a privilege so lucky to do
something so fun and get paid for it but
there is also a dark side to this
industry it's so ironic that I'm now in
the middle of an industry that messed me
up so much when I was younger and made
me feel so bad about myself and so I
think that's why I rally so hard to undo
all the damage that was done to me and
just try and like show all of the
nonsense and the smoke and mirrors of it
all and just tell all of the truth that
no one else knows that's why I don't
allow Photoshop it's why I go makeup
free all the time on my social media I
just want to make sure that we're
transparent I tell everyone all the
tricks and tips and lies
because I think that knowledge is power
[Music]
I don't think anyone really disagrees
with me when I you know cool famous
people out if you look under their post
often their fans are already tagging me
the the that's often how I find out
about it I don't follow
those people I don't follow influences
and models and people who Hawk diet and
detox products because I think those
people suck I've met a couple of them
and they were polite over the years I
don't think they're bad people I don't
want them cancelled I just want them to
stop selling diet and detox products to
kids and then I will you know get off
Fedak I was 19 and I just recovered from
breaking my back in that car accident
and realizing how much I taken my body
for granted and how awfully I'd spoken
to myself all of my teen years I've been
very anorexic before and I looked at why
I hated myself so much and it was
because of the fashion industry and
movies and Hollywood in general in part
and just generally the culture of what
women in the 90s are expected to look
like and so I decided I wanted to fight
back and I started writing letters to
newspapers and I became a model scout so
that I could try and change the industry
from the inside I thought I was Jason
Bourne I didn't manage to have but
instead I moved on to Hollywood where
I've now been able to actually make
significant change so I do think
unfortunately you get listened to more
from the inside than the outside and
that's been a big part of my motivation
to be in this industry
acting is fun hosting is fun celebrities
that like out there okay but the best
part about this is being able to
actually have an audience to change
people's mind to try and change a
culture and I guess that's kind of what
I'm trying to do stop anyone from ending
up as messed up as I was I didn't get
very much sleep last night when it comes
to sexuality and feminism I'm all for
whatever it is that you want to do
something I would like to see more of if
I could if I could have it my way
is more equality in the nakedness so
rather than always having the woman are
naked and dancing and the man sitting on
his ass doing nothing
wearing outdoor winter layers
I would like to see men up performing
for us and pleasing us I'd like to see
some balls
I'm gonna see some boobs frankly my way
as a mental health movement it's not
just about the way that you look it's
about the way that you feel I get like a
hundred messages today from people
telling me that I way has changed the
way that they look at themselves and
mothers saying they bought a bikini for
the first time in ten years or I've had
girls stop me in supermarkets and tell
me that they started to eat again
because of me through their anorexia or
people have stopped wearing so much
makeup people have stopped photoshopping
themselves people feel better about
their mental health like I way as a
mental health movement it's not just
about the way that you look it's about
the way that you feel and we have been
responsible just by telling people the
truth you know we're not out here saving
anyone we're just telling people the
truth it's definitely the thing that I'm
proudest of in my life in my career we
have a responsibility to be transparent
when we have this much privilege in my
opinion
I'm not gonna look in Americus I hate
looking in mirrors so I just tend to
stay away from reflective objects I
think sometimes this whole body
positivity and self-love thing is it's
just a lot for people to have to achieve
it's a lot of pressure to have to love
something that you hate or that society
has taught you to hate and society actor
actively hates it's the ideal but
sometimes it's hard just to go straight
from hatred to love so I prefer
neutrality that's where I'm at now I
can't love my body but I can accept my
body and just get on with it and not
think about it and not worry about it as
much I think that the only problem I
have with this kind of love your body
movement is is that it's still forcing
us to stay trapped in the obsession of
our bodies that still means that we're
thinking about them and as agender
we're behind because we're being given
all this extra homework to do I think
women in particular which would have a
lot to gain from thinking less about our
bodies are more about our bank accounts
and our social lives and our love lives
and you know our families and our
education I think that's where our
priority should lie if we're going to
catch up with men I thought the thin
white women wear like Kate Moss was my
was my sort of idea of beauty when I was
younger but now that's changed and now I
love dark skin I love big lips and and I
like a strong nose which I used to hate
when I was younger I find all kinds of
different body types gorgeous and I
don't see stretch marks as a floor
anymore I like I love mine to the point
where I've got stretch marks all over my
breasts and whenever they were try and
put makeup on them on the good place I
would make them take the makeup off
because I think that that's a part of me
that I'm not ashamed of and by covering
it up it sends a really bad message
I don't really ever feel beautiful I'm
also not interested in feeling beautiful
I just like feeling like myself which is
normally when I'm lying and my
boyfriend's arms I'm not interested in
him beauty terribly I like fashion and
makeup and I like playing with colors
and I used to paint and so I think I
find that quite fun but yeah I never
really feel beautiful I just I prefer to
feel funny or smart or happy
[Music]